[Music]
you look very lovely the first thing I
noticed about you obviously your name
kirby bliss Blanton that's a terrific
name thank you
important in show business to have a
name that just sort of grabs you kirby
bus Blanton it's a little unusual yes it
is I blame my mother I was actually
supposed to be a boy and Kirby's a boy's
name but bliss came from it's actually
my mom's maiden name so that's why if we
passed it down as my middle name so
kirby bliss Blanton and I go by the full
thing cuz why not some people have three
names right sure well stage name a bunch
and I'm like no it's on my birth
certificate right well there are people
that think that I made up the name that
when I decided to go into show business
that my name was chip Whitley and I came
up with Conan O'Brien and and and it was
really the name my parents gave me and
everyone else in my family has a normal
name and they just decided to give me
Conan and I think in a way that's sort
of magical like absolutely that your
parents gave you an interesting name may
have led to things well and not only
that but it'd be pretty difficult to
come into this industry as Brittany or
you know write something that's already
been yeah my brother and I both have
kind of interesting names Brady and
Kirby kids give you because sometimes
kids think I mean we're kids ever mean
to you about yeah I definitely got made
fun of like when I was younger like
fourth and fifth grade I guess there's a
video game um
Super Smash Brothers do you know that I
don't Super Smash Brothers anyone know
about Super Smash Brothers so some of
them are playing it right now so there's
a character named Kirby and it's like
this pink marshmallow type balloon thing
ball and when I was younger some of the
boys would come up to me at school and
say you know Kirby really does a good
job it's sucking and blowing and I was
like what yes that frankly is my
reaction right now
oh so I was very I didn't know I was put
off by that I was like I didn't know
what that meant so I go home and ask my
brother and I guess that's the powers of
this okay oh the Kirby has yes yes
that's what the balloon this pink thing
I've never played the game but that's
what it does it like sucks up everything
in its wind and blows at so at the time
I I didn't know whether or not to be
offended or anyway that's that's that's
Kirby's Super Bowl complimented
compliment
I think offended across the board
everything just saying hey I learned a
new I learned something new about this
now you tweeted recently from the
Playboy Mansion
I'm curious I've never been to the
Playboy Mansion and he's never been to
the Playboy Mansion no how did you get
into the Playboy Mansion okay so it's
not I knew one of the girlfriends she's
in our movie and I did I was lucky
enough I did Maxim with her so after the
photo shoot I was like you know what are
you doing she's like I'm going home
who's like me can I come and it's
interesting because once we got there
you know it was actually kind of dead it
was during the day I'm expecting a bunch
of naked women and I was really excited
and then I get there and it's like just
her and I cool but there were no naked
women I don't know if there was a
certain time that they all come out I
must have missed that I must've missed
that it's like an astrological event
yeah Trump backs up but no actually my
favorite part of the mansion is you can
order whatever you want
I but I she's like are you hungry and I
was like well yeah we've been working
let's see eat she was like you can get
whatever you want and I was like wait a
second I'm big on food I have to be fed
every hour on the hour so it's like I
can eat she's like yeah what do you want
steak fish blah blah blah but I was like
okay I'll get a salad I'll get crab legs
I'll get steak I'll get that and she's
like okay this is the first time in the
history of the world that anyone said
you got to go to the Playboy Mansion the
food is terrific
it's true it's true that was my favorite
part I totally mood stuff with the chef
I was like can I have another one that's
what we're happening to me as women with
naked breasts all looking at me away
from me
rigatoni staff